hello my name's Simon and I'm a
recovering academic and I make videos
about the physics of the Earth's
atmosphere and climate change
this class is about how to talk to an
audience about science and specifically
data driven science in an engaging way
[Music]
so our job becomes finding the story and
framing it in such a way that it fits
into these categories
the fundamental thing to keep in mind
when writing a story is giving your
audience a reason to continue with the
story
I want to talk about the principles of
presenting data and using visualizations
the most important thing you can come
away from this project with is the
desire to make stuff so with that said
let's talk about how to tell a story
[Music]